لقد مرت 20 عامًا تقريبًا كان ثلث
الأمريكيين إما أطفالًا أو
لم يولدوا بعد خلال هجمات 9 11. لكن
ثق بي عندما أقول إن أمتنا كانت
متحدة لفترة وجيزة في الصدمة والحزن
والتصميم وبقدر ما يصعب
تصديقه  حتى أننا تجاوزنا
السياسات الحزبية لبعض الوقت ،
ولهذا السبب ، إذا نظرنا إلى الوراء ، فإنه من
السريالي أن نرى أين انتهى بنا الأمر الآن ،
أعني من كان سيصدق أن
طالبان التي قدمت المأوى لابن لادن
ستعود إلى السيطرة على أفغانستان
بعد  حرب استمرت 20 عامًا وكلفت أمريكا ما
يقدر بنحو 2 تريليون دولار ، ما يقرب من
2500 جندي
أمريكي كانوا يعتقدون أن
رجل رودي جولياني المعروف باسم عمدة أمريكا
سيجد سمعته في حالة يرثى لها
بعد الهجمات التي
شبّه بها تشرشل الذي أشاد به باعتباره برجًا للقوة.
عبر الخطوط الحزبية وكنت فخورًا
بالعمل معه في قاعة المدينة بعد
20 عامًا ، وهو قيد التحقيق من
قبل مكتب المدعي العام الأمريكي حيث
قاد كلماته وأفعاله
دورًا في التنوب  توجت عملية عزل مزدوجة
لرئيس في التاريخ الأمريكي
بدعوة للمحاكمة عن طريق
القتال قبل هجوم على عاصمتها
ومن كان سيصدق أن دونالد
ترامب يتفوق على الرجل الذي تفاخر في 11 سبتمبر
بأن مبناه الآن هو الأطول في
أفق نيويورك  كان من الممكن أن يتم انتخابه
رئيساً للجمهوريين بعد
مهاجمة أجندة الحرية لإدارة الأدغال التي
تحظر الهجرة من
العديد من الدول ذات الأغلبية المسلمة أثناء
التفاوض على اتفاق سلام مع
طالبان استبعد حكومتنا الأفغانية المتحالفة
أو أن تلك
الصفقة سيتبعها الرئيس المقبل
جو بايدن ، كان عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ لما يقرب من
30 عامًا عندما قام
بقاعة بلدية في 20 سبتمبر 2001 مع تبادل إطلاق النار
في CNN بالاشتراك مع الشاب تاكر
كارلسون ، عاشق ربطة العنق لمرة واحدة وهو الآن
مذيع أخبار ثعلب شعبوي محافظ
يعارض الحروب الخارجية ولكن  في ذلك الوقت
كان بالفعل يطرح فكرة خاطئة مفادها أن
العراق كان له علاقة بالهجوم على
المخابرات الإسرائيلية
الآن الكثير عن الإرهاب من
الواضح أنه يعتقد أن العراق كان له دور
في هذه الرؤية التي تكتسب
رواجًا في واشنطن ، هل تعتقد
أن هذا صحيح للعراق دور
وأن يجعل العراق العدو يبدو
أممًا كبيرة لا تستطيع
خداعنا  لا يمكننا أن نفوت هذا الأمر ، لا يمكننا الخروج
والتسبب في التحالف الذي تقوم هذه
الإدارة بتشكيله بشق الأنفس
بما في ذلك العالم العربي
بما في ذلك العالم الإسلامي بما في ذلك
أعدائنا السابقون و / أو
الخصوم المحتملون في المستقبل ،
لا يمكننا أن نخرج هناك ونصنع  خطأ
أو بمعنى إعلان الحرب على كل
دولة آوت بأي شكل من الأشكال
الإرهابيين في
الماضي بالطبع غزو العراق هو المكان الذي
بدأت فيه الأمور بالفعل في الخروج
عن مسارها.  ما كان ينبغي أن يكون
التركيز الوحيد على إيقاف الإرهابيين الإسلاميين المتطرفين الذين
يحاولون بدلاً من ذلك إعادة تشكيل
الشرق الأوسط
بدلاً من ذلك ، العقل المدبر 911 خالد شيخ
محمد.  حتى خليج جوانتانامو وعقد
جلسة استماع جديدة قبل المحاكمة هذا
الأسبوع ، كان من
المفترض أن تتم محاكمته في المحكمة الأمريكية ،
ويفضل أن يكون ذلك في نيويورك منذ وقت طويل
، ولإضفاء مزيد من الإهانة على الإصابة يوم
السبت بينما يحتفل الرئيس بوش
وأوباما وبايدن بالذكرى السنوية التاسعة.  11
نصبًا تذكاريًا في جميع أنحاء البلاد سيقدم الرئيس السابق
ترامب تعليقًا ملونًا
للمعركة بين كبار السن من ذوي الوزن الثقيل
في فلوريدا
كثيرًا حتى لا ننسى أبدًا ،
لكن لا ينبغي لأي من هذه التقلبات المأساوية والمفارقة
أن تصرف انتباهنا عن
تذكر ما حدث في ذلك اليوم
ولا يمكننا الاستسلام لـ 9  11 فقدان الذاكرة
لأن أمتنا في ذلك اليوم واجهت
أسوأ ما في الإنسانية مع أفضل ما في
الإنسانية ، وضع رجال الإطفاء وضباط الشرطة
والركاب على متن الرحلة 93
مثالًا دائمًا لما تبدو عليه الشجاعة في
الديمقراطية
وكأنهم يركضون نحو الخطر لمساعدة
الأشخاص الآخرين الذين لم يفعلوا ذلك.  لا أعلم أنهم
واجهوا النار وأظهروا
التزامًا غير أناني بالصالح العام في
وقت الأزمات ، لقد أقاوم دائمًا
استدعاء هجمات 9 1  1 مأساة ، لقد كان
عملاً من أعمال الحرب ،
مآسي من صنع الذات ولكن هذا
يقودني إلى تطور مقزز أخير ، لقد كان من المسلم
به دائمًا أن أمتنا
يمكن أن تتحد في وقت الأزمات ولكن
لم يعد بإمكاننا أن نأخذ ذلك كأمر مسلم به الآن
هذا شيء  لقد فعلنا ذلك لأنفسنا
ولكن هذا ليس شيئًا يجب علينا قبوله على
أنه أمر حتمي ، وما زلت أعتقد أن
شخصية بلدنا لم تتغير
ولهذا السبب نحتاج إلى التعلم من التاريخ
وتكريم أمثلة أبطال
9 11 الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى
إن توجيه التزامهم
بالصالح العام نحو الدفاع عن
ديمقراطيتنا المشتركة هو التحدي
الحاسم في عصرنا الآن وهذا هو
التحقق من واقعك